talk about the main types of statistical
studies so you could have a sample study
and we've already talked about this in
several videos but we'll go over it
again in this one you can have an
observational study observationally
study or you can have an experiment
experiment so let's go through each of
these and always pause this video and
see if you can think about what these
words likely mean if you or you might
already know well sample study we have
looked at this is really where you're
trying to estimate the value of a
parameter for a population so what's an
example of that let's say we take the
population of people in a city and so
that could be hundreds of thousands of
people and the parameter that you care
about is how much time on average do
they spend on a computer so the
parameter would be for the entire
population if it was possible you would
go talk to every maybe there's a million
people in the city you would talk to all
million of those people and ask them how
much time they spent on a computer and
you would get the average and then that
would be the parameter so population
parameter population parameter would be
average time on a computer per day
average daily time time on a computer
now you determined that it's impractical
to go talk to everyone so you're not
going to be able to figure out this the
exact population parameter average daily
time on a computer so instead you do a
sample study you randomly sample and
there there's a lot of thought and
thinking about whether your sample is
truly random so you randomly sample
there's also different techniques of
randomly sampling so you randomly sample
people from your population and then you
take the average daily time on a
computer for your sample and that is
going to be an estimate for the
population parameter so that's your
classic samples
now in an observational study you're
you're not trying to estimate a
parameter you're trying to understand
how two parameters in a population might
move together or not so let's say that
you have a population now so let's say
let's say you have a population of two
you have a population of 1,000 people
1,000 people and you're curious about
whether average daily time on a computer
how it relates to people's blood
pressure so average computer time I'll
actually let me write it this way
instead of average computer time you
should just be computer time computer
time versus versus blood pressure blood
pressure so what you do is you apply a
survey to all 1,000 people and you ask
them how much time you spend on a
computer and what is your blood pressure
or maybe you measure it in some way and
then you plot it all you look at the
data and you see if there if those two
variables move together so what does
that mean well let me draw so if if this
axis is let's say this is computer time
computer time and this axis is blood
pressure blood pressure so let's say
that there's one person who doesn't
spend a lot of time on a computer and
they have a relatively low blood
pressure there's another person who
spends a lot of time has high blood
pressure there could be someone who
doesn't spend much time on a computer
but has a reasonably high blood pressure
but you keep doing this and you get all
these data points for those 1,000 people
and I'm not going to sit here and draw
1000 points but you see something like
this and so you see hey look it looks
like there's definitely some outliers
but it looks like these two variables
move together it looks like in general
the more compute
the higher the blood pressure or the
higher the blood pressure the more
computer time and so you can make a
conclusion here about these two
variables correlating that they're
positively correlated there is a
positive a reasonable conclusion if you
did the study appropriately would be
that more computer time correlates with
higher blood pressure that higher blood
pressure correlates with more computer
time now when you do these observational
studies or when you interpret these
observational studies when you read
about someone else's it's very important
not to say oh well this this is this
shows me that computer time causes blood
pressure because this is not showing
causality and you also can't say maybe
because might say somehow people blood
pressure causes more people to spend
time in front of a computer that seems
even a little bit sillier but they're
actually the same because all you're
saying is that there's a correlation
these two variables move together you
can't make a conclusion about causality
that computer time causes blood pressure
or that blood pressure causes some time
high blood pressure causes more computer
time why can't you make that well there
could be what's called a confounding
variable sometimes a look called a
lurking variable where let's say that so
this is computer time computer time and
this is blood pressure I'll just write
like that blood looks like building so
blood blood pressure and it looks like
these two things move together we saw
that right over here on in our data but
there could be a root variable that
drives both of these are confounding
variable and that could just be the
amount of physical activity someone has
so there could just be a lack of
physical activity driving both lack of
activity people who are like less active
spend more time in front of a computer
and people who are less active have
higher have higher blood pressure and if
you were to control for this if you were
to take a bunch of people who had the
simulant who had a similar lack of
activity or had a similar level of
activity you might see that computer
time does not correlate with blood
pressure that these are just both
driven by the same thing and what you're
really seeing here is like okay in
people with a high lack of act or who
aren't active well it drives both of
these variables so once again when you
do this observational study and if you
do it well you can draw correlations and
that might give you decent hypotheses
for causality but this does not show
causality because you could have these
these confounding variables now
experiments and experiments are the
basis of the scientific method
experiments are all about trying to
establish causality and so what you
would do is if you wanted to do an
experiment you would take and you
probably wouldn't be able to do it with
a thousand people experiments in some
way are the hardest to do of all of
these maybe you take a hundred people a
hundred people and to avoid having this
confounding variable introduce error
into your experiment you randomly assign
these hundred people into two groups so
random assign so random it's very
important that they're randomly assigned
and that's nice you might not know all
of the confounding variables there but
it makes it likely that each group will
have a same amount of people with lack
of activity or than the lack of activity
or the activity levels on average in
each of the groups when they're randomly
assigned it gives you a better chance
that you know one group doesn't have a
significantly different activity level
than the other and then what you do is
you have a control group and you have a
treatment group once again you've
randomly assigned them so control and
then treatment and what you might say is
okay for some amount of time all of you
in the control group can only spend you
know max max of 30 minutes in front of a
computer and on the or maybe if you
really wanted to do it you say you have
to spend exactly 30 minutes on a
computer and that's maybe a little
unrealistic and then the treatment group
you have to say you have to spend
exactly two hours in front of a computer
and I'm making up these numbers at
random and it would be nice to see okay
what was everyone's blood pressure
before the experiment and you could say
okay well the averages are similar going
into the
Armant and then you go some amount of
time and you measure blood pressure and
if you see that wow this group
definitely has a higher blood pressure
this this group has a higher blood
pressure so the blood pressure the blood
pressure is higher here and once again
some of this might have just happened
randomly it might have been you know the
people you happen to put in there etc
etc but depending if this was a large
enough experiment and you conducted it
well this says hey look there's I'm I'm
feeling like there's a causality here
that by making these people spend more
time in front of a computer that that
actually raised their blood pressure so
once again sample study you're trying to
estimate a population parameter
observation study you are seeing if
there is a correlation between two
things and you have to be careful not to
say hey one is causing the other because
you could have confounding variables
experiment you're trying to establish or
show causality and you do that by taking
your taking your group randomly
assigning to a control or treatment that
should evenly or hopefully evenly
distribute not always there's some
chance it doesn't but distribute the
confounding variables and then you you
on the on on each group you you change
how much of one of these variables they
get and you see if it drives the other
variable so anyway and the next few
videos we'll do some examples of
identifying these types of sample
studies and thinking about what we can
conclude from them or these types of
statistical studies and see what we can
conclude from them